seconds after the first puck drop tomas
noshek followed
the ducks waddled to tie the game at two
in fact there were four goals
in a frenetic first eight minutes of
hockey but the knights settled in and
the stars came out mark stone max
pacheretti and alex tuck
all scored 5-2 the final the stanley cup
run of 20-21
is off to a fast start because this team
steps on the ice with pride
the golden knight logo it it's really
meaningful to us like
we we start from the bottom and
and uh we built uh i think we built
something all together and
everybody i mean the management did a
great job
to make sure that whoever was coming and
joining our team
they were good good people you know good
good guys and a good locker room guys so
it's been honestly it's been a
a great journey but it's uh it's never
going to be uh
satisfying with what we do until we lift
the stanley cup
marchessault spoke of turnover the
golden knights still had 11 guys in
uniform last night who played on that
original
great team there is a lot of pride being
vegas born as you can see
as for game two anaheim in vegas we'll
play again tomorrow night
at 7 p.m kirsten thanks so much john